the Joe Rogan experience but uh and I
would laugh about that that you know my
kids would have musk ox sandwiches or
musk ox tamales and he'd go down to
school with oh that's hilarious
that was great my kids like freak out
other kids at school you know like like
kids at my kids school be like what's
your favorite food my daughter like I
like bear thinks it's hilarious that
she's eaten bear you know she she likes
to tell people bear sausage it's my
favorite and the other kids like what
the [ __ ]
you know kids that have never
experienced any wild game and my kids
have eaten you know since 2012 when I
started hunting they've basically eaten
everything they've eaten elk they've
eaten deer they've eaten ducks they've
eaten wild turkey they've eaten
everything what's there how are they
viewed in their community
like how are you viewed in that that
like school parent community I don't
know it's hard to tell because do you go
to the event yes I got to go to one
today yeah I'm a weirdo for sure but you
ostracize friendly no I'm really
friendly so like most of it it's all
hugs you know like the parent like I'm a
nice guy so when I see those folks it's
all like friendly and hugs but some guys
have pulled me aside and asked me about
manly activities because they feel like
how'd you you're you actually allowed to
be a man and you're everyone's neutered
you know like so many guys are their
wives are yelling at them and I'm off
doing cage fighting events you know and
where were you last week I was bow
hunting you know I was in the mountains
but no cell service and so they might be
inclined to be like oh I don't like that
for like middle America rednecks but
it's okay for you well they know me
right now they don't that the
preconceived notion and they know I'm a
good dad you know I'm very active and
I'm constantly around my kids and I take
it very seriously and it means the world
to me
so like parents one of the moment the
most important things that I find is
good parents respect good parents they
see that you love your children that's
the interesting point yeah I mean if you
find someone who's like
dismissive parent and is not interested
a disinterested parent it's like one of
the most disturbing and disappointing
things if you love someone you care
about them and then you find out they're
a bad person or a bad parent you have to
reevaluate your perspective on them
because to me being a parent and my wife
is huge on this it's like it's
everything to her she will not talk to
someone or hang out with someone if she
feel like they're a bad parent and she
forms her relationships with their
friends based on whether or not they're
good parents it's it's everything yeah
if you're you know you're contributing
to this community so when I'm around
these parents you know I'm a nice guy so
it's all friendly but they all have
questions all these poor men that are
stuck in cubicle jobs you know men men
are tortured you know it's like that who
was it the RO yeah most men live lives
of quiet desperation yeah it's one of my
favorite including Thoreau well he knew
what he was talking about you know it's
uh it's these most people are just
living this boring-ass [ __ ] life and
I'm living this life where I'm telling
jokes in front of thousands of people
and then I'm doing podcasts in front of
millions of people and then I'm hunting
I'm gonna and then occasionally I go off
and do cage fighting commentary it's
like a caricature of masculinity really
yeah people get confused well it is when
I smoke pot so it's like what's going on
here one of the things one of the early
things is surprising about you is man I
don't want to use that words don't want
to be insulting one of the things that
that's more yeah one of these is
surprising about you but it's something
that sounds like [ __ ] issue is how
serious you take being a parent because
I think that someone could look like
someone could someone could add a glance
look be like oh you know discussion of
drugs and like dirty humor and sort of
go like those are not congruous with
parenting but you take soup you pay do
you take parenting like extremely
seriously well but you know I don't
think you you're not like you know
you're not so concerned with people
understanding a full package you need to
spend [ __ ] loads of
I'm telling everybody about how good of
a parent you are yeah I'm not interested
in that I'm interested in love you know
and as a kid who grew up with sort of a
deficit of it and it's very important
for me to spread as much of it as I can
whether it's through my friends or
through a children and to children it's
like the most important responsibility
because my friends would they're fine I
met him there growing up still figure it
out on their own you know I'll help him
when I can but but kids you know it's
like you get one shot at that you get
one shot at raising kids man you know
it's not you can't redo it you can't go
this one sucks let me rip it up and
start from scratch like you have to do
it right and you have to and you're
gonna make mistakes for sure but you
have to spend as much conscious time
talking to them and interacting with
them and really you know I like it I
enjoy it